Roslyn I'm going to start with you uh
first individual question
um I've seen Jai work up close and he's
what we call a diva and I'm just curious
what is it like working with someone who
really is just really difficult on set
always wants to steal other people's
lines I'm just curious I'm just really
glad that someone's finally asking me
about my experiences because I felt
silenced for a very very long time
um you know but there are many open
secrets in the industry
um about people like Jai and it's gone
on for far too long
um I I we don't know this but I was
actually given an extra retainer fee so
that's to babysit Jay
um but uh no I mean he's a nightmare
it's been absolutely awful and uh I'd
love to get that out in print thank you
so much
listen it's also a nightmare when you do
interviews with him he's always trying
to talk you know evade question I'm
joking um
these things have all the answers so
take it from here Rose so
um first of all nice to see you Jack and
then uh so uh one of the things that's
crazy about this series is that you can
watch it in any order like there's no
and so when you guys were first told
that information would you like get the
F out of here this is never going to
work
yeah it's it's a it's a curious thing
and and definitely an original concept
um which you know you know is going to
be a challenge to execute but I think
what they were able to craft with these
episodes all perhaps serving as like a
pilot if you will
um was really I don't know really quite
wonderful and and we you know you each
audience member will start in a
completely different place in the story
and get a completely different
trajectory and I think creating that
unique experience for the viewer
um is really engaging and it's also
going to force people to like put their
phones down pay attention uh and and
investigate things oh who's that yeah
the cats have been joining interviews
I'm so sorry for you know I love it um
but I did create something really fun
and special and I think people are going
to have a ball with it it's not as
convoluted as it sounds it's not kind of
I don't think it gets confusing on any
level we we have a center point that you
will never be too far away from you you
know understanding our geography two um
and then you know you get to kind of
cast yourself into the future in the
past and and even jump you know in and
out of that in you know small gaps of
time which that was my one concern was
like is it gonna are the apps that are
close together gonna confuse people in
there tracking forward and I I don't
think that's the case at all I've seen
the whole show and I I think it's it's
um achieving something really fun and
special yeah I was gonna say I watched
uh the the I've watched three episodes
so far and um I watched them in the way
that the preview content offered it to
me but I'm curious how did did anyone
say to you like a certain order for you
to watch it was it was totally I mean
even reading them it was in like there
was
the kind of slight talk around oh would
you want to like jump here and then jump
there but that's not the point like
having episodes at one I remember at one
stage when I was reading early on
knowing like one was chronologically
going to exist after the other I had to
resist the urge to read it that way but
it's all about
um I don't know investing in in what
this the concept of this show is
supposed to achieve and and it serves
just as well yeah for both of you
um I love just like the audiences uh
just like audiences uh I love watching
heists uh TV and the movies it's just a
genre I can watch endlessly what is it
like to make a heist show like this
where you know because you're all every
series or movie has to up the stakes and
this one has a has a safe that is
practically on on you know you can't get
into this thing your job I know right
safe breaking
um it was really fun I mean it's it's
really great to get to do something like
this where you you as an actor there are
so many fun things that you get to do
and like skills you have to learn and
like
um but at the same time being able to do
it on a show where there was so also so
much heart so much depth to these
characters
um it just felt like being able to
pretty much do everything that you hope
you might like doing this job I learned
how to crack a safe which was pretty fun
um for real yeah for real yeah yeah for
real
um it's really interesting technique and
it's actually incredibly simple you just
have to have a Deft kind of touch and
perception and it's there's not that
much involved with it I'm surprised more
people don't know if I walk around
cracking safes honestly share anything
with the world it's go crash yeah with
the episodes
um which shot or sequence ended up being
the real pain in the es like is there a
specific shot that you know for
technical reasons whatever uh it ended
up being really challenging I don't know
about
shots per se there is a there is a you
know a portion of the story we spend a
large amount of time submerged in water
um or a you know part of the group do
and um you know that got old pretty
quick
[Laughter]
constant
braid and
Ashton water
um and there was a lot of shooting I
think most of it was the shooting the
outdoor scenes for summer when it was
New York winter oh yeah yeah that was I
was blue yeah Rose managed to find
herself in like short dresses all
through like a New York winter and it
was always discussed because we'd be
like well what stuck with the seasons in
this show where are we at because it's
actually one of the things that isn't
necessarily played into to like
specifically yeah and um it definitely
looked you know it was supposed to look
warm on days that you know they're like
literally shoveling snow off the road
um which got painful but we love what we
do you can't uh you've got to be careful
to complain no totally listen I'm lucky
to do what I do you guys are lucky to do
what you do but I I do think that people
behind like audience members don't
actually realize what it takes to make a
TV show and the hours that go on it's
it's cool but it is really a lot of work
it is it is intense and certainly I
think you know it's fun to get under a
rain Tower you know in in kind of minor
zero temperatures
um I'm talking Celsius uh but you know
hour four of that at three a.m in the
morning
um you really start to question some of
your life choices and bear in mind we're
the actors like the crew's been there
three hours before we got there it's
gonna leave three hours if you're
allowed to wear rain gear
totally you can't you can't complain but
it is still worth people knowing about
on that note I really can't wait to
watch the rest of the episodes
um and I wish you guys nothing but the
best thank you so much